so thanks stefan for being here uh
to give this talk uh so we're gonna go
for um
maybe around 40 minutes okay
um great so go for it thank you
thank you very much thank you for
inviting me here uh
i really have great memories about my uh
stay at simon's last year it's it's a
pity that
we cannot make this reunion uh there but
i hope i will meet
all of you at some other occasion soon
when all this craziness with covet is
over
so i'm going to talk about a recent
paper
on plasma that i have together with
gregor fabianski sebastian faust and
shivash
ryaki the paper was recently accepted to
the innovations in theoretical computer
science conference
so i'm going to tell you a little bit
first like give you some rather long
introduction about
what this thing is like what plasma is
but i will also have some time to
describe our technical contribution
so the starting point is the following
observation that you probably
have seen many times even today that
blockchains don't scale well
right so this is because large scale
consensus for long messages is expensive
okay
so you have lots of messages and you
have many parties
then i mean there are different
definitions of what blockchain is but
one thing that all blockchains have in
common is that they need to have a
consensus and this is typically
expensive
so there are some solutions to this
problem one is to work on better
consensus algorithms
another one is called sharding i will
not go
into this and the last one which is
particularly relevant for
for us today is off chain protocols
they are also called second layer
solutions and main idea there
is that we want to use blockchain as a
dad or a notary in real life
so we want to contact blockchain only if
we really have to
main approaches are off-train channels
this is what clara was talking about
a few hours ago and i'm not going to
talk about this
and second approach is plasma or another
newer name is commit chains
this will be our focus today and
in a nutshell what we do is we initiate
study of lower bounds or impossibility
results in this area
okay so before i go to the description
of plasma
let me give you some general remarks
about how you can view blockchain as a
time stamping service because this is
relevant to how plasma works
so one way to look at blockchain is that
it's a public
time stamping service right this is
sometimes people
when they describe blockchain to someone
they
they first like uh
try to to explain it by giving some
analogues to time time stamping and it's
a public timestamping service meaning
that
everything that appears there is public
what does it mean exactly the
timestamping service so the first thing
is that it gives ability to a user
to prove that he knew some message m
at some time t okay so i can sign some
something on the blockchain and then
maybe one year later i can say okay i
knew this thing
already at time t because uh
[Music]
i signed this and that's and that's on
our timestamp on the blockchain
uh by the way messages are often called
transactions and i will use these two
terms interdimensionally
and moreover the second point is
stronger namely that m is publicly
available
at time t okay so you have two there's
two requirements
one is that simply i'm i want to have a
prove that i knew some message another
one
is that i want to prove that i also made
this message public
[Music]
this is also called data availability
this problem okay because
it will turn out soon uh proving that
i knew some message is not the same as
proving that the message was published
uh so uh uh how does it look like in the
most naive
view you have some user and she has a
long message m
can potentially long and puts this
message on the blockchain
and this is the timestamp right that
this message was was there
actually people use blockchain for this
purpose
okay so there's natural idea to relax
this requirements a bit
and maybe say okay we only care about
proving the knowledge of m
we don't care about proving that m was
publicly available
then we could optimize time stamping in
the following way
what we could do is whenever i want to
stamp stump
a long message m i would just apply a
hash function to it
and put h of m on the blockchain right
it's kind of an obvious idea because
then i can later prove
to everyone that i knew this message at
the given time
but just by showing the message and
pointing to where it was
where it's hash appeared on the
blockchain
and this thing can be optimized even
further so if you have many users say
here we have five users but it can be
much more
and they each each of them has a message
mi then what they can do is they can
choose one operator send messages to
this operator
the operator would concatenate all
messages into
into one message m and send m
back to the users and at the same time
send a hash of this message m to the
blockchain
so okay so that is two things right the
operator needs to
hash the message and sign it and send it
to the blockchain
and then also needs to provide back to
the users
the entire message m right because they
want to be able to verify
to prove later that their hash was
included right
uh of course it can be optimized with
miracle hashing you can
do it in logarithmic way without sending
message m to everyone just logarithmic
path fine
um okay call this message uh hash in
timestamp it's my own
name no not not just for the purpose of
this talk
okay a national question now is what can
go wrong if the operator is malicious
so he may not publish the hash right
but this is like obvious to everyone
that he's misbehaving if he's not
publishing
when he promised to do so publish some
harsh and but not include some mis
right this is still not so bad because
this means like if i'm a user
okay i i know that my message mi was not
included but
uh yeah i should just take some other
actions it's like you know
an attack of non on liveness
and the last thing that he can do is he
may not explain hm okay by explaining
h m i mean he may not provide m to the
user so he
here on this slide he would not send
this message m
so and this is this precisely what's
called data unavailability right that
some hash was not explained
and the protocol for time something
would simply work in this case like this
every user constantly monitors the
blockchain and monitors what the
operator does
and if something doesn't work like if
for example hash wasn't published or
maybe was not explained
then the the user will just say okay
this thing's with this operator didn't
work i'm going to do it myself and he
say himself publishes to us
right so you have these two scenarios
optimistic and pessimistic the
optimistic one
is that if the operator is honest then
everything goes smoothly and then this
method saves a lot of blockchain space
and the pessimistic scenario where the
operator is dishonest but then still
nothing really that happens because the
only price compared to not using this
service at all
is that you know maybe i wasted some
time trying to
convince the operator to
to publish to include my message but
yeah in the worst case i do just myself
so we have this weak version of time
stamping
proving that the message was existed at
the given time
and it's cheaper but weaker security
guarantees
and the stronger version that is
that says not only that the message was
known at time t but also it was publicly
available
and the differences are of course that
the first one is cheaper
uh than the other one but then this
gives you more security guarantees
so natural question is that maybe for
some applications
this weaker guarantees would suffice
right
so for example in academia we kind of
use
this idea of time stamping to claim
priority of the results
right and then what is typically assumed
is that you need to make your paper
completely public
right if you want to claim the priority
uh
this is to encourage people to to
publish actually right so
if you could just publish hashes of your
papers
and then 10 years later claim okay maybe
you know
i i invented some uh
some great things ten years ago that
became published now by someone
then it doesn't really prove anything
right i mean that was my choice not to
publish this
[Music]
but it still provides some information
right so if i have a hash of my
beautiful ideas a pdf somewhere
published on the blockchain then later i
can at least prove that
this idea was not stolen from someone
right
and then the question is maybe we could
emulate the strong time stamping using
the weak ones right
and the focus of this work in the focus
of plasma
is kind of addressing this problem in
the cryptocurrency problem
in the cryptocurrency context
uh and therefore we will use terms like
transaction fees to describe
the something costs on the blockchain
publishing messages on the blockchain
costs
okay so this brings us to plasma are
there any questions
okay this was like kind of simple
remarks about time something right
i mean basically everything on this
paper will be simpler hopefully
okay so main idea of plasma is to apply
this hash and time stamp trick
to the ledgers okay this was introduced
by pun and buttering
three years ago and the main idea is
again we will have an operator who will
have his own
private ledger l and he will
publish l off train for example on his
web page
and periodically for example once an
hour he will publish the hash of l
on the main train so the um ethereum
blockchain
in a in a smart contract
okay so there will be this special
plasma ledger that will be maintained by
the operator
made off train available to everyone and
committed
or a time stamp on the blockchain
frontline so what is the
this plasma ledger it can
there are different flavors of this but
let's say the users own tokens the stock
escape the
exchangeable with coins or some other
tokens on the real blockchain on the
main chain
and every user can exit plasma ledger at
any time so if
i had some tokens on plasma ledger i can
always leave the ledger with my tokens
so for example at the beginning the user
deposits some tokens on the main chain
then some time passes and the user can
withdraw maybe some other amount of
of talkers on the main chain if some
transactions happen
so one way to look at this is uh that is
kind of like a virtual bank
by virtual bank i mean that's okay in
this case we have three parties
and say everybody has some
some amount of coins in the bank so
alice has five and so on
and then if alice wants to send money to
bob say one coin to bob
then the operator will subtract one coin
from alice's account and add to
the bob's account so alice's account
decreased and uh bob account increased
by one
uh
and of course the problem is that uh it
all becomes
sort of official when
the operator publishes his next
commitment his next time stamp on the
blockchain right
so
finality here is not great but
the saving is in
the blockchain fees
so what are the periodic commitments
again so
also we can call them timestamps so we
have operator and smart contract and
simply the following happens right so
from time to time say one hour
each one hour the operator hashes the
ledger
and publishes the hash on this smart
contract
okay so how does it look like say
suppose we have users and transactions
and there is the operator uh
and yes the operator gets uh uh
yes gets the transactions t1 up to t5
from the users and computes
a ledger li so the new
version of his ledger from the previous
one
and the new transactions and sends it
back to the users
um uh
again this li can be published simply on
the web page of the operator
and then at the same time uh hash
of uh this new ledger is also published
on the block
on the main and the users need to
constantly monitor
uh situation and react if
uh sorry if something happens to be here
main challenge is of course handling
data unavailability right so
this is what happens when the operator
is nice
but he may also be malicious and do some
bad things and in particular the hardest
thing to handle
is what if the operator does not explain
hush okay
so i know that something was hushed
i don't even know if my own message was
hushed there
and i don't know what was there at all
like i don't know what were the other
transactions
yet i know that the operator did
something
so this is this data unavailability
problem
and the main features of plasma are that
as long as the operator is honest plasma
provides huge savings on transaction
fees
dishonest operator cannot steal money
if there is a conflict between the user
and the operator they can always use
smart contract to resolve the dispute
and again it's important that every user
constantly observes what happens
on the blockchain and
on the web page of the operator to see
if everything is explained and
everything is okay
okay so this was proposed three years
ago and
soon after this there were many variants
of this plasma
this is a picture from like i think two
years ago so that's
far from being completed i think some
projects here are already abundant
uh there are other new projects and
yeah some academic work renames
plasma to commit chains so it's a commit
chains are
the whole family of those and then you
have different types of plasmas or maybe
other names
the main two types of plasmas are
a plasma cache when tokens are
independent entities
each so each talk so there are tokens in
the system and each token has some owner
and that's
limited but simpler and easier to
implement
and then you have fungible plasma there
are other names like plasma and vt no
cast i think start decks is also a
version of this
uh where users have accounts where they
can have some number of tokens
it looks almost the same but there are
important differences between these two
yes so plasma cash is a strange property
that tokens cannot be divided or merged
they are not non-fungible that's how
they call it
think of them as game items so maybe a
sword or
an armor or whatever some items from a
game and in fact
first one of the first implementations
of this plasma cache came from the
gaming industry
so how does ledger in plasma cache look
like we have n tokens tokens have some
identifiers they are from one to n
there are m users in the system just to
simplify things and assume that
set of users is constant and ledger
describes to whom a given token belongs
right so
uh where bottom
means that the token was withdrawn so
for each
token i will have some user who is the
owner ordered to connect with drone
there is one drawback though
so this this thing
has the following problem that if i have
k
coins or k tokens
[Music]
and i want to exit this plasma
then i need to communicate omega of k
bits to the blockchain so if i had
uh 1000 tokens then i need
to kind of withdraw each of them
separately
that's why also you cannot do things
like
say okay let's say one satoshi is a
token right
the smallest possible value in the
system because then it would mean like
normally you would have huge
transactions
okay fungible plasma is better it's also
called
plasma mvp or minimal viable plasma
again knockouts and start decks
so tokens can be divided and met
arbitrarily
uh and the plasma ledger simply defines
uh
as usually in the bank uh just
you know users and their accounts right
so you have user you've u1 has x1
tokens u2 has x2 tokens and so on
right so this is like a standard bank
uh yes and think of it as real numbers
of course
in reality we have finite precision but
and then it's much better because to
commun to exit with k
coins you need to just communicate all
of lock k
bits so exiting even with large amounts
is is efficient so you have this
two types of plasma i haven't told you
how they work and i have no time to do
it
so you have to trust me they exist uh
plasma cache
has large exit size pessimistically
fundable plasma has short exit size
so this column looks like plasma
fungible plasma is better but there is a
second column
which uses a term that i will explain in
a moment
uh so this term
is non-uniquely attributable mass exits
and non-uniquely attributable ex
must don't exist in plasma
cash but are a problem in fundable
plasma okay
so there is a trade-off and there is a
certain problem that fundable plasma has
that plasma
cash doesn't have i will explain it in a
moment
okay so again what if there is a data on
availability
so if the operator didn't
uh explain given hash
so what plus a fundable plasma does is
okay so here's the situation where
say there was l i was explained still l
i plus one is not explained
so i don't know li plus one
then what plasma fungal plasma
tells the users just exit plasma as soon
as you can
take your money and run something is
wrong
and this doesn't exist in in plasma
cache plus markers doesn't have this
problem
even if you see that something is wrong
you don't need to immediately escape
why this is a problem
yes so so first of all if the operator
really disappears and stops
explaining stops explaining his hashes
then every honest user has to do it so
every honest user has to
uh escape from the blockchain
immediately
this can cause congestion on the
blockchain and therefore you need long
timeouts
for this okay and this is a problem
because
typically you don't want to have a
very long time outside i mean they were
like last time i checked they were
saying like two weeks for example
uh and moreover
the this whole thing is non-uniquely
attributable
which i will explain in a moment but
basically it means the data
unavailability is subjective
so i can claim that data is unavailable
allo can claim that actually data is
available
and from the point of view of blockchain
it's impossible to
prove for each of us
who is right and who is wrong
so what are these uniquely versus
non-nuclear attributable faults so
nuclear rebuttable fault is a situation
where
smart contract knows which party is
responsible for a problem
uh this has several advantages one of
them is that you can say okay
every user will put a deposit aside and
if
we see that he's cheating will penalize
him and this
penalty will come will will be used to
cover the fees for example right
uh or to compensate some other laws
uh even loss of time so examples of
uniquely attributable fault is that the
part doesn't send some message to a
smart contract
or science to contradictory statement
statements
uh non-uniquely attributable faults are
a different situation
where a smart contract knows that some
party is not following the protocol
but he doesn't know which one so this is
precisely this problem
when for example i'm sending a message
to allah
and i'm claiming i did it and allah
claims it hasn't arrived
and this is a problem because it also
leads to this
phenomenon called griefing so
well uh the problem comes from the fact
that
it's not clear who should pay the fees
for resolving the conflict
natural approach is if we have a
conflict so for example if
i i was supposed to send a message to al
and we have a conflict if
this happened then uh um
we'll go do it via blockchain right so i
will now alice
ali complains about me to the smart
contract and smart contracts explicitly
asks me
to send the message right then there are
not real
transaction fees and then we say okay we
split them 50 50.
uh of course this is a problem because
this may not still not prevent some
users from misbehaving uh for example
if i want to destroy my competition and
i'm richer than my competition
it may be okay for me to pay 50 50. and
this is called griefing i think this 10
comes from like
computer games i can grieve someone
it will cost me but it will also cost
him uh
yes vitalik was writing some papers
about this
uh and there is a real life uh situation
observed in a system called fanfare
that's actually uh in such situations
users honest users often pre uh prefer
not to fight on the blockchain right so
this is some kind of a channel system
in this channel system if i have a
conflict with someone i should go on the
blockchain and
try to resolve it but it costs so much
that makes no sense for me to do it
and of course then the the other party
knows that i would have no incentive to
do it so it's actually incentivized
to maybe apply this attack and create
problems
okay so again what is the difference
plasma cache and fungible plasma exit
size large short
but here no uniquely attributable mass
axis and here
a problem with of non-nuclear
attributable must exist okay so
if the operator stops explaining his
hashes then
everybody has to quickly run and the
question is is it inherent
so can we have a plasma that has short
exit size and no must exit at the same
time
one reason why one why
one mistake about that is
the case is that plasma cash is simply
is simpler to describe and simpler to
implement
so it's an obvious advantage so maybe
people were actually
doing this plasma cache thing only
because it's simpler not because it has
some inherent advantages over plasma mvp
which is harder to implement
okay and this is the question that we
address in the paper
okay so some some terminology
when i say attack on plasma i mean a
strategy
for the adversary who corrupts some
users and
for the environment to tell the honest
users what to do
and mass action of size alpha is a
situation where the honest users need to
quickly send
messages of total length at least alpha
to the smart contract
uh even if they were not instructed to
exit right because if we allow
if we don't write this then we would
have a problem because of course
the environment can simply tell everyone
to exit and then
of course always mass action can be
caused
why do i need to use the term mass
action instead of mass
exit that's because
we uh uh it can be the case that
it must exit me kind of means that you
exit the whole train and
must actually means that you just have
to interact with the blockchain maybe
uh you still stay within this same smart
contract with your token but it's just
put on some safe account this is a
technicality
and our results simplified are that
there exists and
for every plasma system pi with m users
there exists an attack
on plasma that causes non-uniquely
attributable mass action of size
encoder with significant probability or
there exists an attack that causes an
exit size
of an honest user to be at least m over
four
again with significant probability okay
so i can do these two things either
uh i can make if you give me plasma then
either i can make this attack so this is
like this plasma mvp problem right that
i can
either cause that must exist or i can
uh
i would not have this problem but i will
[Music]
pay in the sense that large exits
from on the exits from on the studios
maybe that
there's a caveat here we have an
additional assumption that
so according to our definition of plasma
the users don't communicate with
themselves they communicate just with
the operator
okay so what are the implications of
this again uh
this is the copied from the previous
slide so suppose
plasma we have a plasma with
non-non-uniquely attributable mass exit
actions of any size
then or large size then one doesn't hold
right
there for two has to hold uh sorry this
alpha is not needed here
and this means that plasma needs to have
exits of size of
m4 right and the other way to look at
this okay so suppose this doesn't hold
those only short exits then one has to
hold so i need to have mass exits over
large size
okay so let me in the remaining few
minutes let me tell you about
how the proof works uh
so the proof is i mean it's usually i
think the case with like lower bounds
that
some even very intuitive things need a
lot of work if you want to make them
formal
so we make it all formal in the paper
just let me tell you what is the main
intuition
uh okay so we have users we have
uh usually one who will play a special
role
and the operator and
at the beginning each user's user has
his own token right the operator has no
tokens but
otherwise everybody has a token
and then we choose a random set s which
is a subset of these guys
right so this is our guys from u2 up to
u n
and i choose the run on set s so this is
the set s
and this is these are the remaining
users
and what the these users do is
they are this you use some set s
transfer all their coins to user u1
and then user e1 immediately exits with
these coins okay so
since the set is a random then kind of
like
around half of the coins or half of the
tokens disappeared
now this is the first thing that happens
from a random
address
and the operator
is nice to these guys okay so he's
talking to them no data unavailability
he's also talking to you one he's
ignoring these guys
so so so he's launching a data
unavailability attack on them
okay and then there is a second phase so
we have again the set s and
all the remaining users and now
this user is really telling malicious
and they start to
pretend that they actually haven't
transferred these coins okay so this is
done by some kind of rewinding
of machines they say okay i will now
pretend i'm
i'm a good guy and i haven't i haven't
uh transferred my coin
before and then we say okay all the
users let all the users exit
the plasma chain
so these users exit
plasma chain they are honest users
instructed by the environment
and these are users who are malicious
users who are pretending
they haven't transferred their coins
and the problem of course is that if any
of these guys manages to exit
then we have broken plasma it's not that
we
made some like uh
non-nuclear attributable fault we just
broke plasma completely because this
means if one of those exited with
his token then there will be not enough
tokens left for the good guys to exit
right so at least one of them loses
money
so it's very important now that the
honest users would actually
convince the smart contract what is the
set s
so they need to go to a smart contract
and convince what is this
test
and the intuition of course you should
be much more careful in the real proof
but the intuition is that uh
in order to convince a trust smart
contract about the situation like
who exited
the smart contract needs to know the set
s in advance so after phase one
because otherwise there is no way to
prove who is actually
lying and who is honest so we have two
options
either in this so this is again the
first uh first phase
either the users uh from uh
the set in the first phase from the set
u to u2 um minus s either all of them
said okay there is data unavailability
we need to do large communication to the
blockchain to kind of
let ourselves be heard that we call we
complained about
data and availability right
or and this is another uniquely
attributable mass action because
again data and availability is
subjective or
this guy in this phase one when he exits
he needs to
put a long information on the blockchain
so that s can be reconstructed from this
okay so we are using the fact that
the maybe i should have said it earlier
i mean we are using the fact that if you
want to
uh have a description of a random
subset of m elements
then you need kind of m bits for this
okay so formal prophecy in the paper the
conclusion is that there is a good exam
good plasma is a good example
for the difference between weak and
strong time stamping so
for plasma cache uh it's
different than from plasma mvp and
another conclusion is that there are
good theoretical reasons why actually
people were working on
two types of plasmas not one so
this simply depends on what is more
important for you
if you care more about short exit or
more about data availability problem
um i think allah knows more than me
about
starkdex uh last time i checked
you had something like data availability
committee there right
if you so you have like a special so
this is kind of like a
trick to bypass this problem that you
you you assume that you have some
committee with honest majority that
votes about if
data was available or not of course this
this is a solution but it kind of
changes the model
uh so kind of this result shows that
uh it's generally unavoidable
unless you give up on some uh
assumptions that we made
and yes the practical community
in this especially this ethereum people
they are working uh at least one year
ago they were
talking a lot about roll-ups or zika
roll-ups
so they were kind of like a way to solve
this data availability problem in need
and underway
uh that was a year ago i don't know what
happens now with this because somehow
often they change uh uh focus but i
think zika roll-ups
are actually implemented uh and aren't
zika roll-ups just
uh kind of this uh fungible plasma i
mean they're
it's basically it's go ahead
i think in in as far as i understand
relapse
there's this way that you actually make
this data available for a moment
uh on the uh
on the blockchain all data is available
uh
so like you have miners certifying that
this data was available
and then simply it disappears from kind
of like the state of the contract
i mean you have this difference between
like light clients and and
full nodes and i think full nodes will
always store it but light nodes will not
okay like i think of roll-ups as
basically the mechanism of proving a
batch of transactions but then
kind of whether the batch of
transactions is reflected in some data
on the blockchain or not it can
some sort of orthogonal property but
yeah like
typically they're understood to be like
with data on chain uh
i think the technical trick is that they
put it as inputs to the function call
and the inputs are not stored uh forever
i mean not not like by the light
but anyways that's like um i mean it
doesn't look
doesn't lead to like to scalability i
mean it's primarily like um
yeah okay that was it
uh questions
thank you thank you